[Musique]
Michel David José Legault Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir annonce
importante complexe parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de ramifications mais
importantes en immigration aujourd'hui
je fais entendre tout de suite pour
mettre la table sur le goal qui dit vous
allez me poser la question j'avais dit
non c'était pas possible 60 000 je dis
oui voici pourquoi on écoute
je m'attends à avoir la question ce logo
vous avez dit plus que 50 000 ça serait
suicidaire mais ça serait suicidaire
pour l'avenir du français mais à partir
du moment où on est capable puis une
réelle ouverture de la part du
gouvernement fédéral de dire
l'augmentation c'est seulement les
francophones ou des gens qui maîtrisent
le français ça vient complètement
changer la situation
le gouvernement lui-même a certains
moments il a ouvert la porte au
francotrope moi je pense que c'est une
erreur grave si on ne regarde pas
d'autres bassin comme les bassins
francotrope il y a beaucoup de gens une
langue ça s'approbre quand on vit au
Québec le plan ne propose pas et moi
j'ai pas vu de mesures concrètes pour
permettre et favoriser une
régionalisation de l'immigration comment
le gouvernement du Québec va réussir à
nous expliquer qui leur ont pu deux
engagements le 40000 en 2018 le 50 000
en 2022
voilà ça c'est l'opposition qui
réagissait je vous montre un tableau
puis je vous laisse parler on parle de
l'immigré des immigrants permanents on
parle pas des temporaires on va en
parlant discussion alors ce qu'on dit
c'est que dans la portion que contrôle
Québec la portion économique qui 65 % à
peu près du bloc immigration en
permanente on va passer de 88
actuellement 96% autrement dit la
connaissance du français ce sera pas
uniquement des points bonus ça va être
une exigence d'entrée Michel David tour
de table qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de cette proposition monsieur Legault
nous dit ouais 50000 ça suicidaire mais
maintenant plus qu'on peut aller
chercher des immigrants qui vont parler
français avant d'entrer au Québec le
problème serait mais le problème c'est
que quand monsieur quand le Parti
québécois disait ça il faut que on exige
l'entrée le français à l'entrée monsieur
Legault disait c'est pas possible
maintenant ça a l'air que c'est possible
monsieur Legault disait sans tous le
pouvoir du gouvernement fédéral c'est la
louisianisation bon ben là les pouvoirs
sont pas là mais on est corrects alors
disons que c'est une autre illumination
de monsieur Legault après le troisième
lien maintenant il découvre que en
matière de migration on peut très bien
sauver le caractère du français avec les
moyens du bord parce que monsieur
Legault disait il y a des entreprises
qui ont besoin de main d'oeuvre puis des
gens qui parlent pas français on va les
francisés après le la ministre m'a
répondu oui mais ceux-là ils vont aller
dans le temporaire de toute façon il y
aura le temps d'apprendre en tout cas
José première impression
souscrit à ce que Michel vient de dire
premièrement deuxièmement on a
l'impression que
c'est quand même un virage important
c'est à dire bon le premier c'est de
dire oui on va augmenter quand même le
pourcentage de d'immigrants économique
qui vont maîtriser le français moduler
le selon certains besoins mais ça c'est
un pouvoir que le gouvernement du Québec
avait déjà je sais pas qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement fédéral vraiment vient
faire là-dedans le deuxième virage c'est
le discours lui-même son immigration la
taxe fait beaucoup reprocher avec raison
je pense de présenter toujours
l'immigration comme une menace aux
Français la louisianisation la
disparition etc et là tout à coup
aujourd'hui on a présenté l'immigration
comme un moyen de lutter contre le
déclin du français c'est nouveau ça de
sortant de la bouche de Monsieur le GO
c'est quand même un virage majeur et là
on voit une espèce de moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on va assister à une
cohésion frontale politique entre la
caque et le Parti québécois la carte
vient de se détacher complètement du
particulier quoi sur ce terrain-là
politique et la raison je soupçonne
c'est que je pense que les attaques du
Parti québécois font mal à la CAQ
lorsque le PQ dit ben vous voyez le
gouvernement le goût en restant à
l'intérieur du Canada peut pas vraiment
rien faire il y a pas capable d'aller
chercher des pouvoirs supplémentaires en
immigration je suis capable de faire des
miracles avec ce que j'ai déjà
et donc et donc le sous-texte de ça
c'est parler nous pas de souveraineté
s'il vous plaît c'est pas ça l'outil
dont nous avons besoin moi je vous dis
que non seulement je l'avais freiner le
déclin du français mais je vais même
renverser la tendance à
son lait politique exactement avec les
pouvoirs que j'écris ça du four parce
qu'il dit dans mon jardin je suis
capable d'attirer plus de francophones
de sorte que
l'immigration va devenir la solution
plutôt qu'un problème aux Français
il y a un changement d'approche si on
regarde le thème de l'immigration au
sens large par rapport au Québec je
trouve qu'il y a un versant positif et
un versant négatif le versant positif il
y a eu la fermeture du chemin Roxane qui
est quelque chose de très important on a
fermé le robinet jusqu'à un certain
point au filon des immigrants
temporaires puis tous ceux qui disaient
que ça changerait rien qui explique
après on voit bien que ça change quelque
chose de fondamental la fermeture du
Marocain mais aussi tout le débat sur
l'initiative du siècle qui était 5 qui
est nécessaire et de façon générale ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on est
capable de débattre du thème de
l'immigration qui est un tel crucial
pour l'avenir du Québec français sans
que ça les soulignant là c'est très
positif la conférence de presse
après-midi que j'ai regardé était d'un
bon niveau bon on nous explique la le
changement d'approche que désormais on
va exiger que déjà des gens parlent
français mais évidemment versant négatif
il y a deux groupes bémol là-dedans moi
ça me dérange pas que je suis le gros
évolue dans ces prises de position on
n'est pas politique de Sam scandaleise
pas du tout le 2 gros bémol évidemment
c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce des
immigrants c'est quand même 358
personnes qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le
robinet
il faut quand même assumer nos succès
les Québécois mais il reste que beaucoup
de ces gens-là ne parle pas français
puis leur événement nous dit il va vous
en parler plus tard et en fait l'autre
bémol c'est que il y a un scepticisme de
ma part puis aussi de gens qui sont dans
le domaine j'ai fait mon petit sondage
après midi allez garde la capacité de la
machine administrative à livrer la voix
chantée c'est bien beau les conférences
de Price les bonnes politiques les beaux
changements bon puis je trouve que
c'était de bon niveau je le rappelle la
conférence de presse mais j'aime pas le
dire mon est devenu sceptique sur nos
machines administratives fédérales des
Québécoises est-ce qu'ils sont capables
délivrer la marchandise donc tant mieux
tout ça mais ça nous convient pas
totalement c'est un bon point Michel je
vous relance là-dessus José allez-yves
je vais relancer Michel après je vous
allez-y oui
tout à fait raison mais c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'on assiste à un
positionnement qui était essentiellement
politique je sais pas qu'il faut douter
là de la volonté du gouvernement actuel
de vouloir essayer de au moins de
freiner des classes français que tout à
coup il a vu la lumière là que
l'immigration ça peut être une bonne
chose c'est pas toujours une menace loin
de là
mais c'était essentiellement politique
parce que d'ici l'élection de 2026 très
honnêtement comment on fera pour mesurer
tout ça comment on fera pour mesurer
vraiment les résultats sur le terrain
parce qu'en effet il y a toute la
catégorie des temporaires qui sont
extrêmement nombreux à plus de 300 000
aujourd'hui donc est-ce que le Québec va
investir les ressources nécessaires pour
aller franciser les personnes qui ont
besoin d'être francisés ça
et la ministre à la question dit tout à
l'heure oui justement on va mieux les
francisés mais Michel David je disais la
ministre c'est l'éléphant dans la pièce
en effet ne serait-ce qu'à cause du nom
trois plus de 300000 il y a là-dedans là
pour que les gens nous suivent il y a
des étudiants étrangers il y a des
études il y a des travailleurs
saisonniers il y a des travailleurs
qui ne sont pas permanents donc ça peut
aller jusqu'à un an et demi deux ans
même qui reste ici et qui dans plusieurs
cas Michel David veulent rester ici
alors là la ministre promet une voie
rapide quelqu'un qui est en région qu'un
métier de soudeur qui a pris le français
il veut devenir permanent il pourra le
devenir plus rapidement nous promettons
encore faut-il que la machine suive il
faut que la machine suive d'ailleurs on
a comme réparer le PEC qui était une
espèce de voie rapide le programme
d'expérience québécoise on s'est rendu
compte que on avait
Eric complètement mais la machine c'est
une machine à deux temps qu'on a ici on
voit c'est très beau même si Québec fait
diligence celui qui donne le hoquet
final il est toujours à Ottawa et on l'a
vu dans le cas des étudiants africains
mais bien avant qu'on parle de ça on
parlait de la pile qui qui n'était pas
de s'élever des demandes qui provenaient
du Québec de gens qui avaient eu leur
certificat de sélection du Québec et qui
était en attente d'une décision à ta
voix pendant un an deux ans ça finissait
plus alors ça on nous dit kotawa va
collaborer mais ça fait longtemps il me
semble qu'on entend ça que la
collaboration vient pas tellement vite
d'autres parts un sujet qui a pas été
évoqué du tout dans le document ni en
conférence de prête souvenez on disait
toujours il faut tenir compte de la
capacité d'accueil du Québec la capacité
d'accueil du Québec le peu qu'on en dit
dans le dans le document de consultation
de la ministre c'est que c'est quelque
chose de très compliqué c'est pas facile
à évaluer autrement dit on met un peu la
charrue devant les bus c'est à dire on
décide d'avoir des migrants mais on sait
pas quelle est la capacité d'accueil
alors ça éventuellement puis quand je
parle de capacité d'accueil là je peux
pas nécessairement de francisation je
parle de logement je parle de garderie
je parle de soins de tout ça et ça on
n'en sait pas plus que qu'on en savait
mais comme vous avez souligné vous trois
à votre façon ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on
va s'occuper de nos pouvoirs en matière
bon immigration permanente le volet
économique et on dit on verra si le
fédéral mais on est plus dans le
discours Michel vous avez dit de si j'ai
pas les autres pouvoirs de fédéral on
devient la Louisiane
mais mais moi je trouve qu'il faut
rester positif dans ce dossier le
poisson bruit dans le défaitiste et
c'est variétal le Québec c'est affirmé
positivement et politiquement
Roxane a été fermé là ça peut être
magique parce qu'il est pressions au
Québec Ottawa a été obligé de dire non
l'initiative siècle ça nous intéresse
pas et le de façon positive parce qu'on
prochaient beaucoup gouvernement le
groupe xénophobes
et ça c'est un progrès je trouve que le
côté pragmatique le job est dans les
détails un dossier dans le devoir sur ce
thème là qui est très intéressant
aujourd'hui et ça attire entre autres
l'attention sur le fait que concrètement
il y a des gens qui sont à Montréal des
gens peut-être qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile donc il faut arriver récemment
qui travaille puis qui ont pas le temps
d'apprendre le français puisque on les
libère pas de leur travail pour qu'elles
prennent le français les cours de
français sont pas payés moi c'est tous
ces détails là qui sont importants voilà
je trouve qu'après midi de la conférence
de presse c'est positif puis le Québec
est plus enfermé dans une image d'une
femme négative ça c'est un succès que le
gouvernement réussi elle est une très
bonne communicatrice moi j'aime pas le
défaitiste dans le sociologue très bien
conclusion José après je passe au
salaire
oui ben c'est ça c'est justement c'est
sur le terrain quelle ressource
financière quelles ressources humaines
vont être investies pour que ça puisse
fonctionner et ça sont laissés depuis 25
ans ça a été un gros problème et le
gouvernement a le mérite de se mettre en
marche de se mettre en action oui il le
fait beaucoup pour des raisons
politiques il y a le PQ qui lui sauf un
petit peu dans le coup etc ça va mais
faut quand même saluer que ça bouge il
faut peut-être pas de manière parfaite
et que le discours encore une fois son
immigration tout à coup par magie
devient positif et non plus négatif ça
devient une solution plutôt que le
problème donc le salaire le salaire des
députés ça a commencé mardi un
accrochage entre monsieur Legault et
Gabriel a dos Dubois qu'on va écouter
ensuite la suite de l'échange
aujourd'hui encore ça fait trois jours
que ça dure on écoute
ça fait des promesses qui avancent pas
le temps d'attendre aux urgences et
place en CPE les logements abordables le
premier soit aussi fait des promesses
qui ont brisé le troisième lien la
réforme du mode de scrutin souvent il y
a jamais promis sans campagne
d'augmenter le salaire de sa gagne de 30
000 dollars par année pourquoi s'est
rendu aujourd'hui sa priorité
j'ai entendu
à plusieurs reprises le chef du deuxième
groupe d'opposition dire sur toutes les
tribunes faire arrêter de faire de la
petite politique ça aurait été de faire
de la vieille politique ben c'est
exactement ce qui fait actuellement
donc a dit nous accepterons seulement
une augmentation à la hauteur de ce
casque ce qui sera consenti aux
enseignants aux enseignants donc là on
essaie de moduler ce qu'on va recevoir
tour de table c'est pas fini cette
discussion là
Dubois s'est trouvé son serment du roi
vous savez le dossier de serment du roi
qui avait fait tellement bien
là il y a un dossier gagnant moi je
trouve et je veux dire j'ai changé
d'idées moi sur ce thème là dans un
premier temps je trouvais que c'est
normal qu'on augmente le salaire des
députés mais quand tu regardes le
dossier de façon plus large c'est vrai
que ça marche pas le fait qu'on s'occupe
pas du fond de pension qu'on avait
qualifié de Ferrari bon qu'on s'occupe
pas des allocations puis en plus la
déclaration de notre premier ministre
qui peut être suave sur les raisons pour
lesquelles il fallait augmenter mais ça
va des députés bon moi j'en suis pas
revenu la façon dont s'y prend pour
acquis qui a été député c'est comme
n'importe quoi d'autre le je veux dire
c'est normal que les députés veulent
être payé le plus possible pour donner
de l'argent à leurs enfants député c'est
une fonction publique il faut les payer
comme il faut faut pas les payer trop
donc du bois je suis pas un fan toujours
de lui mais je trouve qu'un dossier
gagnant et il arrachera pas là j'ai
l'impression
oui parce que on peut être pour on peut
être contre cette augmentation là de 30%
quand même mais il reste que le moment
choisi est vraiment inopportun là c'est
le moine qu'on peut se dire en pleine
négociation justement et c'est ce qui
chicote aussi c'est et ça c'est Michel
David qui avait posé cette question là
au ministre drinville en entremet la
table éditoriale du devoir le ministre
invite n'a jamais répondu à sa question
pourquoi est-ce que
les élus se voteraient une augmentation
substantielle qui ferait qui serait les
mieux payés de toutes les assemblées
législatives provinciales au Canada en
même temps qu'on a des enseignants qui
sont parmi les moins bien payés au pays
et comparaît pas Michel il comparais pas
la job d'enseignants
de cette iniquité de traitement par
rapport au reste du Canada et ça à cette
question là évidemment on ne s'étonnera
pas que le ministre jamais répondu et le
conclusion parce que
vous l'aviez dit sur ce panel d'ailleurs
cette fameuse phrase qui est devenue
virale et d'ailleurs le ministre aurait
pu le voir avant on l'a souligné donc
Michel ça est-ce que ça se est-ce que ça
se complique pour le gouvernement ou ça
va ça va passer
c'est ça la nouveauté je trouve parce
que l'opposition des chiffres s'achemise
ça fait 40 ans qu'on propose des
réformes puis l'opposition des
chercheurs le gouvernement recule tout
le temps cette fois-ci la différence
c'est que mon impression que c'est que
monsieur Legault a décidé de faire fille
de toutes les oppositions de tous les
commentaires une fois pour toute on
verra ce qui va être obligé de passer le
bâillon mais ça c'est la nouveauté dans
ce débat là merci beaucoup à vous trois
bonne soirée au revoir au revoir au
revoir bonne soirée